[Music]
that's there's lots of psychological
problems with money money is a wonderful
invention
it lets us save it lets to specialize
right I couldn't be a professor if there
wasn't any money every day I would have
to raise chicken and bread and broccoli
and go ahead and spend all my time
trading so money is a wonderful
mechanism money is also very difficult
to think about so we we think about
money is the opportunity cost of money
so we at some point went to a Toyota
dealership and we asked people what will
you not be able to do in the future if
you bought this Toyota now you would
expect people to have an answer but
people had were kind of shocked by the
question they never thought about it
before so the most we got was people
said oh if I can't buy this Toyota if I
buy the third I can't buy a Honda so
they were making a substitution from the
same product in the same time but in
reality this is not a substitution their
subsidy is having for the future in the
future I will have to give up two weeks
of vacation and seventy Latins and 1,500
books I don't know what exactly the
translation is but when we do consume
something now something else has to give
at some point what is this thing what is
this shadow value of price very hard to
think about it so that's a huge
psychological barrier so we're actually
trying to develop an iPhone app now that
the droid is out we'll do it for that as
well if we ever learn how to program on
this thing but the idea is that to make
money concrete so you come to this app
and it's not out there but you'll come
to the app and you say I like vacation
in the Bahamas shoes letters and books
and now when you're tempted to buy
something that thing translates in terms
of the things you're interested in so I
said hey this particular item is like
half a day in the Bahamas two shoes and
one Latin which one of those is better
now in reality we think that comparing
everything to money is great but the
reality is that it's very hard to think
about money it's so general it's so
abstract that we don't really know what
we're giving up in what we're gaining so
if I gave you now $10 as a gift how
happy would you be would you be happy as
the module $10 the best use of $10 that
you can use of course not if I gave you
a CD you know exactly what you're
getting and you
daanyik value for it so money has kind
of lots of problems with it
with money we really fool ourselves
something we are our biggest enemies
with money and there's some things we
can do about it automatic deductions are
a wonderful thing right ideally you
should wait until the end of the month
you can see how much extra money you had
and you should put that in your savings
account we don't do that well if we did
that we will never save so what we do is
we take money out of our pocket into a
saving account in the beginning of the
month
take it outside of our control and as a
consequence we spend less and save more
this is by the way a very good trick
when you say if I realize my own
decision-making at every moment I will
fail many many times if I think once
very hard and create a standard of what
I want to do and create an automatic
execution that will take out the money
every month from my bank account then
there's good chance I'll behave better
not because I'm making good decisions
because it's making it for me so I think
automatic deductions are one thinking
about money in concrete terms so when
you come to think about buying something
usually we compare within categories for
example you go to a restaurant you look
at the wine list and you never say to
yourself my goodness for the difference
between these two bottles of wine I
could buy 3 gallons of milk right we
just don't think like this we compare
wine - wine and milk - milk and beer -
beer but in fact it's how we want to
think now it's very hard to do it in an
extensive way but when you face
something you could say what else could
I get if I didn't get this and which one
of those is giving me the greatest
pleasure now it's not always that we
always need to save more and spend less
I think the question is are we
allocating our money correctly across
into different categories money is a
great way to get happiness right lots of
wonderful things you can do with money
the question is are we really optimizing
on that so if you think about getting
lattice and getting cable which one of
those is actually giving you a great
greater happiness and if you had to cut
in one of those which one would you
would you cut and so I think thinking in
terms of concrete in concrete terms
would would help us a great deal
there's another thing we call the pain
of paying Michigan
there's another idea called the pain of
paying this was proposed by George
Lowenstein and Rajan frileck and here is
the idea imagine that I own a restaurant
and imagine that I discover that people
come and they eat 50 bites and they pay
fifty dollars and one day I offer you a
great deal I say you know what today
could be half price 50 cents per bite
and moreover and only charge you for the
bites you take and you're going to sit
there and you're going to eat and I'm
going to sit there with your wallet and
every bite you take I'm going to take 50
cents from your wallet and transfer it
to my cash register now it's going to be
a very efficient way to eat because
you're not going to spend much money
cheaper plus all in the bytes you eat
but how much fun will eating be not very
fun right why because it turns out that
this simultaneity of eating and
consuming or enjoying and paying
actually makes things less happy here's
another example imagine you go on a
cruise to Alaska and you can either pay
six months in advance or the moment you
get off the ship it's much more
reasonable economically to pay the
moment you get off the ship but how much
would you enjoy the last day of the
cruise it will be kind of miserable
knowing that tomorrow you have to pay
all this money so what happened is that
this simultaneity is very important and
we can use it in two ways we can think
about how we reduce the pain of paying
so for example credit cards are
wonderful mechanisms to reduce the pain
of paying if you go to a restaurant and
you pay in cash you would feel much
worse than if you pay in a credit card
why you know the price there's not
surprised but if you frame cash you feel
a bit more guilt it's a bit more
difficult it's kind of more painful to
part with your money with the credit
card adds another time so you can think
about this is good or bad if you want to
spend more money in restaurants use
credit cards more than cash if you want
to spend less use cash more than modern
credit cards but in general we can think
about how to use the pain of paying and
how much if we do we want and I think we
have like a range credit cards have very
little pain of paying debit card have a
little bit more because you feel like
today at least it's coming out of your
checking
and cash has much more but you can even
do better than cash imagine that you had
envelopes and your envelopes were
telling you how much money you have in
each category for the for the rest of
the month you had an envelope for coffee
you had an envelope for restaurants you
had an envelope for grocery now when you
take money out you also see how much
what you have left is shrinking and that
would actually increase the pain of
paying more now I don't think we should
go around life and being miserable all
the time and feeling the pain of pain
it's a question of what categories we
want to spend more on and what
categories we feel that we're spending
too much on and we want to cut down
[Music]